patrick question pour vous quelques
chroniqueurs et le plus est plus sympa à
l'antenne que dans la vraie vie bien
d'amandiers là pourquoi parce que dans
la vraie vie le
un jour je voulais aller rue marbeuf
d'acheter une petite veste et il n'a
vendu beaucoup trop cher bernard montiel
a battu en mai une question pour vous
bernard estimez vous être plus populaire
que benjamin castaldi
non non ah c'est beau non non non pas du
tout non
ah oui vraiment ouais ben j ai très
sympathique selon le connais depuis des
années non oculaire on me dit popp n'a
pas pu non mais pour le public
pour ceux qui reconnaissent plus
castaldi ou vous dans la ruine ans quand
elle dit ah oui avec toutes ces femmes
et tous ces machins là tout ce qu'il a
fait comme toutes ces couvertures de
magazines et les plus connus que moi non
c'est pas des magazines cd émissions de
télé mais bon si vous deviez devenir un
titulaire indiscutable dans l'émission
détriment d'un chroniqueur ce serait qui
ce serait qui gilles bah ouais jilib
aminta n'est tout à l'heure là donc je
dégage
je suis content qu'elle est question
pour vous on vous voit blonde on vous
voit brune visiblement pour vous
cherchez êtes vous bien dans votre peau
une question du public ouais je suis
enfin bien dans ma peau mais bon dossier
vous étiez bien non oui j'étais bien
mais j'avais envie de changement comme
beaucoup de femmes un moment donné dans
leur live même moi je moi je suis bien
au ballon de six mois
voilà les trois jours vous allez changer
bah voilà exactement vous êtes bien
ouais je suis très bien vous êtes
contente de cette couleur weight réponse
est importante par les coiffures de
bernard montiel j'aurai une question
pour vous tout à l'heure mais juste
avant jean michel jean michel avez vous
déjà vraiment flirter avec une invitée
de tmp si oui laquelle
avec une invitée eva longoria plutôt
elle qui m'a chauffé les autres mon nom
je crois pas clara morgane un tout petit
peu mais bon c'était dur et chauffé
trouve tout clara morgane et le mytho on
aurait dit la vérité parce que kara nous
regardons plus haut merde
son mari font tous ici dit leur personne
non non j'ai tout fait personne je crois
des chroniqueuses c'est tout a dit ici
les invités d'épisodes spieser mais non
mais avec qui vous avez flirter vous à
dire vrai mais oui vous êtes conquois à
fleurs sécheresse et et séduire mais non
chez avec oui mais bien trop loin kenza
du loft
oui c'est parce que c'est la vérité
jewel vient du rack'am à la région
natale il est tous les jours et tu
m'avais déjà sorti ça en plus il a dit
qu'il avait la cote avec vous quoi oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai que dire nathalie
nathalie qu'il a dit qu'il avait la cote
avec vous non c'est pas tout à fait vrai
saisie avec tout le monde ne le dis pas
pour moi je te rassure vous a déjà
chauffé jean-michel que la vérité
sincèrement oui il ya eu un truc dans
une loge un jour oui mais c'était dit
fake c'était pour web ont quand même
est-ce que il vous le sentiez sérieux
non parce que je on se connaît on se
connaît un peu dans la vraie vie il y en
a un mais anniversaire chez moi à oui je
n'invite pas beaucoup de people en fumée
et au nom des talibans bien on a des
amis communs de longue date et non en
page puis on n'a pas du tout ce rapport
de séduction donc pas encore on peut
être surtout des voix ce que vous êtes
déjà sorti avec un invité de l'émission
l'émission d'une de vos émissions même
un anonyme - invité ou quelqu'un est ce
que vous avez dû un gain croche avec
jean pierre pernaut
jean pierre pernaut seraient bannis je
vole pas le mari de des autres oui ça
m'est arrivé non quoi avec un mec de ces
bons choix oui à 9,7 c'est mon choix
oui un anonyme bref quelqu'un qui venait
comme ça pour il avait une phobie commun
il avait une phobie et quoi il ya eu il
ya encore pendant l'émission vous avez
senti que se passe un truc non c'était
s'était pas franc jeu
je n'ai jamais rien avec cuba les six
importants non non on avait fait une
émission spéciale ou où on avait fait un
espace de tournez manège pour moi
c'était rigolo de faire et en plus vous
aviez eu l'idée quelques temps avant de
faire un tour de manège de people
exactement et comme l'émission s'était
pas fait mach aussi dit mais pourquoi on
fait pas un tournez manège et beaucoup
fait ça dans ses manches pour coiffer
pas à tournez manège pour pour se marrer
avec moi il ya des candidats que vous
allez kiffer ouais non et vous avez vous
êtes reste un peu avec l'ubs a pas
longtemps comme un temps une rude nuit
[Rires]
je suis le choix et puis après terminée
non non non c'est le jeu c'est pas le
lundi 6 mois en six mois oui ouais ça
havrais santé et vie merci mais
attendez-vous on peut pas le coupé
samantha je pense que je vais avoir les
prises et les réveillons ne coûte rien
on m'a déjà à ces coupures la descente
merci
[Applaudissements]
benjamin en toute honnêteté
combien de fois avez-vous de la pietà
vous fait de la chirurgie esthétique en
tout honnête si j'ai fait une
liposuccion alors les liposuccions plus
la poitrine mais ce sont mes sincères
ils n'ont été judicieux léger alors
d'une et juste des faits en décembre le
20 décembre c'est prévu soit déjà deux
noms je les et vous n'avez pas fait un
petit break au visage
je fais une injection gratin m'exposer
pas énorme
c'est tout mais de lâcher tous ses sauts
vérité bonjour vous rêvez jeudi tout
adepte enfants au moins c'est fois donc
être gratuit quel qu en soit rené on
sait que vous êtes fan de l'om est
objectivement quelle équipe est la plus
forte entre l'om et le psg
question jugent idiot alors pdg d'accor
a très bien non mais c'est bien ils nous
prouvent rien qui la serbie il fallait
faire garder un camp c'est 1000 euros
pour ne peuvent rien sur balles d'accord
mais là y'a rien l'accord va très bien
benjamin oui quoi sortez-vous de
l'émission avec votre casque de moto sur
la tête c'est pour éviter de prendre des
photos avec nous c'est peu lui qui vous
demande alors oui on aurait dit alors
pas d'aphasie tous refusés met une photo
d'accord mais bon heureusement nous
sommes et alors ben non mais je refuse
super n'est pas ce que vous avez votre
casque avec des moyens je n'enlève
d'ailleurs souvent voilà je vous dirais
franchement c'est une c'est une fausse
avant-garde c'est vrai ça c'est une
faute
je n'ai jamais refusé une seule photo
mais mon restaurant jamais de l'aveyron
a jamais d'accord très bien là les
questions suivra seriana tient là
beaucoup avec des temps qu'est ce que
vous préférez animé tpm paix ouvert à
tous où être chroniqueur sûreté pmp je
préfère animer ouvert à tous ah oui
j'adore ouvert à tous c'est robin simone
préféré quand je suis pas là n'ont
d'ailleurs jamais donné en tant que
chroniqueur dans on verra tous une fois
[Rires]
c'est vous qui payez le cacher
dire non mais c'est tout sauf du camas
et les mauvaises langues le ferait pour
vous avec grand plaisir
mais comme je vous aime et je le ferai
pas où je rigole pas bah voilà en
novembre je le ferai pas ce que je
ferais l'émission après vous ah oui je
fais tes pmp tout le mois de novembre
est bas avant j'aimerais dans on verra
tout ça je pourrais venir après moi en
tant que chroniqueur bien sûr à entre
vous se sera pas payé isabelle en toute
franchise alors ça c'est une question
qui me met sur le q q est ce que c'est
vrai qu'alain votre mari ne peut pas
blairer cyril hanouna je crois pas du
tout somme bien du tout et ça que je
sois dans l'émission ce qui est pas la
même chose
du coup je rentre je rentre plus tard
c'est ce dont je suis amené à parler de
lui même quand je veux pas un peu comme
une gym et donc mais vous me pose du
tout il vous aime bien grâce à vous il a
vu l'équipe 2 de handball en bas très
bien c'était c'était le rêve c'est que
moi que j'aime beaucoup en plus oui vous
voulez en question avec grand plaisir
que je prends alain match pour vous
prend les deux si vous voulez à la
maison géraldine parmi les chroniqueurs
qui selon vous est le moins intelligent
autour de cette table moins
intelligentes et jacent face bas
globalement le niveau est très élevé
quand même donc je dirais
jean michel maire le son du moins telle
une entrée très belle question pour vous
vous dites que vous adorez regarder à
prendre ou à laisser alors quoi
dormez-vous devant les missions que vous
êtes en loge moi quand je n'aurai ce que
kaka camille sol et run est à côté de
moi on regarde toujours ensemble j'en
témoigne rené en train de boire son
pastis comme si on est fatigué l'autre
c'est ça qui courait le husa autour de
la table est demandé de l'emmener fogiel
parce que on peut pas entendre que
justement parce qu'il parle à une
question pour moi ah tiens selon vous
qui est le pire animateurs du paf
aujourd'hui arthur jeu gilles pas
toujours ça change pas gilles vous avez
été absent de l'émission durant quelques
mois vous êtes vous remis en question
oui bah oui et vous avez vous mal est
remis en question aussi je me remets
toujours en question mais oui bien sûr
mais j'étais dans l'émission avec
valérie le j'adorais mais oui je me suis
remis en question
j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi j'ai
essayé de bien sûr pas trouvé faire
baisser restait alors vous avez fait des
efforts parce que vous êtes meilleurs
stades et je trouve ben c'est gentil
mais j'essaie de moins crier à l'essai
de encore plus travailler donc voila
quoi mais c'est pour moi il faut gagner
sa place chaque jour dans l'émission
encore plus travailler et gagner ça
passe tous les jours dans l'émission
vous avez la philosophie inverse de jean
michel lalle
isabelle si laurent rue qui vous propose
d'intégrer la bande des grosses têtes
vous soyez prêtes à arrêter tes pmp
alors arrêtez pmp nantes si je peux
faire les noeuds c'est bien bavé
l'oseille
ça fait pas mal je sais pas du tout
combien moi je suis un couple s'est pas
mis la barre haut mais s'ils prennent le
nom mais moi c'est pas pour alors
honnêtement s'étant jamais l'argent et
aurait eu des résultats pas le top 20 à
écarter j'ai peu près de la fin que du
début comme tu le dis toujours fait en
béton c'est un petit truc bonus qui se
quitteront plus avec la fin du qe2 le
boulevard voulez vous les voulez quoi
que l'inter ait abandonné voulait que
vous vous intégriez après et puis elle
me l'a ni l'autre ne l'a fait passer son
réveillon ninon panne on n'a qu'à faire
un truc les petites têtes de série ont
fait tous les deux ont failli
démissionner c'est la grosse rigolade
j'aime bien moins alors eh ben je vous
invite à approcher maigrin l'accord
maintient dans la grosse là isabelle je
t'invite quand tu veux ma chérie une
folle ou quoi c'est fait et je considère
que c'est fait rené si vous n'étiez pas
mariés est ce que vous auriez pu vous
mettre en couple avec isabelle si la
belle n'était pas varié aussi pas
chiante
je suis pas sûr en temps mais alors oui
j'aime pas les femmes tiennent à battre
est bien de quel projet alors question
cyril pourquoi valérie n'est pas là
cette semaine valérie lé bain vous savez
c'est les vacances scolaires scolaire
son fils à 51 ans maintenant
forcément là ils passent le bac dans un
mois la voilà à quoi donc en quantité
libre donc forcément obligé de rabâcher
voilà isabelle sera de retour la semaine
prochaine et ce qu'ils appellent et là
tout le temps valérie il sera là la
semaine prochaine